hello everybody welcome to a video about
vc
package manager it's actually a redo of
an earlier video i did on this subject
so i just thought i'd make a clearer
more concise version because
let's be fair let's be honest that old
one was
it was a little long-winded for no
particular reason mostly because of my
lack of experience with vc package
manager so
i've uh i've used it some i've learned
it some more i used it for a few
projects
and now i'm just gonna whiz you on
through it without
any of the nonsense or at least less of
the nonsense and more clarity so we're
mainly going to be focusing on
windows here and we're also going to be
looking at
mainly using it with visual studio and
letting it be the package manager for
visual studio so that we don't have to
manually add libraries to each of our
projects
we can just download them once with
visual studio uh package manager bc
package manager
so you'll find vc package manager so i'm
just gonna search google for
vc package manager so you basically just
if you search for it you'll find it
there's a github microsoft link
and you just click on that so this is
how you get it you have to clone it
that's the basic way you do i guess you
can get the zip
you can go to releases and get that but
we're just going to clone it in this
case
so once we're here and we're all done
with that we can move it aside
and you just want to open up whatever
you used to clone with uh
i've got a git shell here but i've also
used fork which is it essentially does
the same thing
it's just uh some software to help out
yeah
so i've got it downloaded here
actually is the repo and uh since i've
last
worked with it there's actually been
some updates so this is really
frequently updated which
is you know that's probably a good thing
usually a good thing
lots of breaking stuff so i'm just going
to go to my master here and
right click and go to pull if you've
done it with command line show i'm sure
you already know how to do this if
you're stuck on gate you should probably
look at some
tutorials on git or something but it's
just a get
pull on when you're on the repo okay and
i can hit console here to go right to
where it is
and i have it on my e drive and storage
source repos
vc pkg now this in this shell and this
ming
gw64 shell i'm probably not going to be
able to run
the commands so i'm going to open up my
standard command line here for windows
standard command prompt and i'm going to
run them all
in that one so cloning is the first step
and you can have it
multiple times each uh each clone of it
and
wherever you clone it you can clone in
different directories each clone of it
is a different set of library management
so if you only need one maybe you're the
only developer or something
then you probably only need to clone it
once but if you want separate library
management you just clone it somewhere
else
and do these configurations that i'm
going to show you so
you can see here that i had to change to
my e drive and then i just changed
directory to where it was
so now i'm in the directory so the first
thing you do is you run a bootstrap
bootstrap and just hit tab
let it auto complete and you'll get this
bootstrap vc package.bat i'll make this
a little bit larger
and just hit enter and this is going to
build everything
building vcpg.exe i've done this one so
i don't necessarily need to do this
again but since
i did just do a pull i guess it can't
hurt i didn't really
look to see if there are any code
updates or if it was just other stuff
but this shouldn't take too long it's
just going to run through compile all
this cpp code
and maybe we can take a quick look at
what this code was while it's doing that
like they fixed a build error on linux
and there's a bunch of stuff here
it's not anything that i know exactly
what it is so
not too concerned and it looks like it
finished
i don't know if this happens to you guys
but for some reason my command prompt
only goes so far
before it just decides it's going to
stop showing me what's going on and i
always have to hit enter in it
i don't know if that happens to anyone
else it's probably just a setting i have
somewhere
okay so now that we've done the
bootstrap the next thing we need to do
there's a couple things we could do we
could just start messing with libraries
or i guess the thing you really need to
know though
i'll show you the things you need to
know that that's where we'll go
you need to tell you need to set it so
that visual studio
uses this one and the way you do that is
you just type in
vcpkg integrate
install and hit enter and that now tells
your computer especially when you launch
visual studio because it's like pre-set
up for basically
to use this vc pkg
it uses this folder for all its
libraries
so if you have visual studio already
open when you do this you need to close
visual studio and reopen it
but now what happens is when you open
visual studio and you make a c plus plus
project
it now looks for libraries based on
anything you've downloaded and installed
it does the linking and the including
headers for you so you just don't need
to touch
any of that which is really cool so the
project i have open here
is a project i've been working on for a
while called ancient archer it's
it's like a game pseudo game engine
scripting game engine
but i was manually handling all the
libraries before
and i've just deleted all those
libraries i was
manually handling because now i can just
do them all with v
c p k g so i'm going to right click on
my project and just show you this is
something you normally do with visual
studio normally you set up the
directories normally you set up the
library stuff you can just set all these
to default or leave them defaults or
change them if you want but
basically what i did in my project is i
set them all back to default
because now there's this configuration
area called vc
pkg and it says use it yes this is
default here i didn't change any of this
and uh yeah so now it detects that and
it uses that so i've actually got
glm glad and uh opengl stuff
asim and uh one other glfw
installed and it now just works like i
can just hit
start on my little sample project here
and just confirm that it's using all the
libraries like if this works it's going
to be load models using glfw
using glm and using one of the other
ones that i said what does this have
tape on myself
all right so yeah it loads up everything
it uses those libraries
i can play around here my project works
and i no longer have to manage
these libraries on my own i can now just
let me
see pkg use them so how do you install
libraries you might ask
because that's sort of important well
you just go to your command prompt and
you go
vc pkg search and this will show you
every single one so you probably
don't want to do this you want to give
it some some variables you know like
search glm or
search uh poco or you know whatever
library you're looking for whatever c
plus plus library you're looking for
there's there's a ton of them of course
you can search for any of them
and when you find the one you want you
just install it you just
you'll see the name of it come up like
so there's special versions if you type
it in with brackets you can get these
special versions
but what all i had to do was vc pkg
i did glm tlfw3
vlad and asim oh i need to put the word
install here
yeah you can just do one at a time or
you can chain them like this and it'll
do all of them
but something that is rather important
and that is
the triplet files this is something i
missed in the first tutorial and
probably the main reason i'm redoing
this
other than the long-windedness of it so
triplet files what are they
by default it sets it to x86 windows
so if you just like just go through what
i went through and just
install this it'll install the x86
windows version of it so
what you can do say we want glm
i'll do glf w3 if you want the x86 you
just put a colon there in x86
or x64 dash windows and that will give
you the 64-bit one
this is the default if you don't touch
anything it just gets you the
the 32-bit binaries which apparently
really annoys a lot of people
because i was reading online and uh
let's see
here it is let's just go to the top of
this here install 64-bit packages as
default instead of x86
and someone says i believe nowadays you
should just do the x64
lots of thumbs up someone said you can
just set a system environment
for this so if you don't know how to set
a system environment i'll show you that
in a minute how to set your system
environment variable to this
that just does it by default but you
know there's some comments
go on down here and some of these things
are pretty interesting basically it's
everybody saying hey
why isn't it just 64-bit why isn't
microsoft got up with
caught up with the times why is it
64-bit lots of people being like
yeah yeah uh
so yeah someone says you can just do
this colon x64
thing if you want to do it individually
but then someone comes down here and
like actually explains
there are reasons for it to be 32-bit
it's something to think about i
i don't know a steam survey says that 99
windows users are running 64-bit i'm
sure you are everybody pretty much is
these days
uh someone's in here says hey they're
parts of visual studio they're 32-bit
still
and that if your program isn't using
over three gigs of memory there's a good
chance that it's more efficient as a
32-bit program i don't know how true
that is but it's just something to think
about
this guy here says it i'm sure no one
upvoted it but that doesn't mean
anything after all the most popular
thing does not mean it's the right thing
my impression is that windows
in the windows world the saying goes use
32-bit mode unless you have a good
reason to use 64.
hence everything defaults to 32. um
32-bit
programs are smaller more memory
efficient sometimes faster by being more
cash friendly
so it's not about market penetration of
the 64-bit cpus or anything else
if you need to map more than three gigs
of memory you need or you need faster
numerical operations sure switch 64-bit
otherwise
it's fine so yeah you just got to type
it in here and if you don't want to have
to do that every time
for every install you can set your
environment variable and to do that
just click your start menu down here and
type in
environment variables you'll see it
it'll pop up edit the system environment
variables it's part of the system
properties
so there's other ways to get to this i
think you can right click here and go to
system
and it's probably in here somewhere yeah
so
uh you just want to click on on this
then click here it's under advanced tab
environment variables
and you'll see here there's system
variables at the bottom there's so so
there's like your user ones
and then there's your system ones and
all you do
is let's see i've already added in here
i think yeah
pkg underscore default underscore
triplet and then you just type in x64
so you would do is you would just
literally put this in here
i click new this
fault triplet and then
x 64 windows
it's probably going to say it's already
in there yeah same one and then you hit
ok
and now you know you don't have to put
this it will just
automatically get the 64-bit once
as you can see it tried the 64. i've
already got this installed
so if i install i don't know let's just
install poco
it tells me what it's going to do looks
like it's getting all the x64 once
now i want x64 specifically because hey
if you're building a game engine you're
probably doing 64. there's definitely
going to be a point where i'm going over
three gigs of memory
and that's what i've been working with
is 64. so yeah
and that's basically it you just install
the libraries you want and when you
when you run visual studio you'll just
have them
automatically you know it'll just pick
them up here
and you'll just be able to include
whatever you've done so you need to look
at the documentation for the library but
now
that poco is installed i'll be able to
just add it here i don't i don't know
how to use poco very well to be honest
but another thing to keep note of here
is once you
install new library you generally have
to close visual studio
and reopen it when it's done because it
usually has to do that before it picks
up the new library so
just fyi i think that's pretty much it
i'm really not going to get into
anything further this is really all
about using
visual studio but you will see here if
you're using cmake
your find package will now actually work
to find these libraries
so in your main cmakelist.txt you can
just put in this fine package
for whatever library config required
and then target link libraries it'll
tell you exactly what you need to type
in your cmake
to use these libraries and there's a
little bit of info about
pointing it to the vc package manager
cmake2
but there's just one more thing you need
to add to it let's uh let's take a look
i think it's right here in this
main github repo and if you're using c
making an ide yeah okay when you do your
build
you need to do this tool chain pile file
that is your path
to vc pkg scripts build system vc
yeah so you'll see that if i go to let
me see here
so if i go to this i'll just do open and
file explorer
we'll find in there what it talked about
scripts
cmake it's in here so the file you need
to point to
with that cmake command if you're using
cmake is in there
so that should cover the cmake end of it
as well
and that's basically it yeah you
basically clone it
run the bootstrap and then install but
before you do this install make sure
you're getting the right version
by doing that environment variable thing
or like i just talked about tells you
how to search
do the integrate install for visual
studio to pick it up
oh and you can also type list to see all
the libraries you've installed so far
good luck have a good set a word
i have a good luck getting visual
or vc pkg going and be sure to update it
frequently if you're using it there are
like daily
updates to it a lot easier than
compiling them yourself this does all
the compiling for you does all the
linking does all the including i know
already said that but just reiterating
at the end of the video here to make
sure it's clear all right well thanks
for watching
hope you uh enjoy using this i'm gonna
do conan next i'm gonna do
uh yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna do a
tutorial about conan and how to use it
to manage your libraries and if you
don't want to miss any of my updates
because occasionally
things change or make corrections or new
cool stuff comes out about coding and
things so subscribe that's that's what
i'm getting to here
please do the subscribe thing so that
you are
notified of course hit the bell if you
really want to be notified and i'll try
to keep you up to date on all the cool
stuff in the coding world
also do some tutorials on video editors
and stuff and i have a patreon
shout out to the patreon please go there
and maybe consider
you know helping out buy me a coffee a
beer whatever it may be i would really
appreciate it
and i'll get some special stuff up there
including you guys getting to vote on
what content i make next and at some
point i'm going to have a discord for
the members there only
where you can chat and interact with me
daily or ask me questions or
community questions and hopefully we can
get a nice group of people that knows
how to do
a lot of cool coding stuff and we can
help each other advance
all right peace out guys have a good one
[Music]
you